en campaña prometió tomarse a la
pandemia de kobe 19 más sencillo que su
rival ahora con un plan de estímulo de
19 billones jobvite en dice que es el
momento de pasar a la acción
6 es una crisis de profundo sufrimiento
humano está a plena vista y
y no hay tiempo que perder tenemos que
actuar y tenemos que actuar ahora
la propuesta de bailén incluye 415 mil
millones de dólares para combatir la
crisis sanitaria que se ha cobrado la
vida de más de 388.000 estadounidenses
el presidente de elektro describe la
actual distribución de la vacuna como
una farsa dice que espera que durante
sus primeros 100 días en el cargo haya
100 millones de inoculaciones el plan es
entregar 20 mil millones para centros de
vacunación comunitarios y unidades
móviles unos 50.000 millones serían para
ampliar las pruebas y otros 130.000 se
destinarán a la reapertura de las
escuelas además de combatir la pandemia
bailén afirma que también hay que tener
en cuenta sus consecuencias su paquete
de ayuda incluye un billón de dólares
para los hogares estadounidenses con
pagos directos de 1.400 dólares a todos
sus ciudadanos esto se suma a los
cheques de 600 dólares de ayuda
aprobados en diciembre además el
demócrata quiere aumentar el salario
mínimo a 15 dólares por hora y entregar
15 mil millones en subsidios de cuidado
infantil a familias de bajo
ingresos y sé que lo que acabo de
describir no será barato pero si
fracasamos nos costará caro costó este
país de asegura que hacen falta
inversiones audaces para hacer despegar
la economía pero se espera que muchos
republicanos en el congreso se opongan a
estos costos aunque el presidente electo
cuenta con que los demócratas tendrán el
control de la cámara y el senado